uh lots for us to discuss then with the
shadow Health secretary West Street and
good to see you this morning Mr Street
good morning can we start with that
police report out this morning hundreds
perhaps thousands of and I'm using very
temperate language here bad apples if I
were not doing a breakfast program I
might be rather stronger it it is
disgrace isn't it yeah it looks less
like apples are more like an orchard uh
and uh This concerns me for two reasons
one is the public needs to have
confidence in our police and I think
over a whole series of misconduct
scandals I think public confidence and
Trust in the police has been severely
undermined and then I mentioned the
orchard I do actually feel really sorry
for the majority of police officers who
go into the force for the right reasons
and are no doubt sick of turning on the
TV in the morning on programs like this
and seeing their their reputation uh the
reputation of their profession dragged
through the mud so our plan to deal with
this is both to ensure that there are
consistent National standards across the
country in terms of conduct but also an
overhaul of this standards regime
because Yvette Cooper's Shadow Home
Secretary has been working on this for
many years not least as chair of the
home Affairs select committee where
she's raised concerns previously still
we should not forget that the reason for
this report the reason pretty Patel
commissioned it was the murder of Sarah
everard which took place here in London
on Sadiq Khan's watch well and to be
fair to Sadiq he was very robust in
challenging the Metropolitan Police and
its previous leader and I remember Sadiq
taking criticism at the time for calling
for the resignation of the Met Police
Commissioner and when you see what's
emerged the criticism was that he held
on to Cresta dick for far too long and
look I think Sadiq also got criticism
for acting when he did the mayor's
between a mock rock and a hard place as
the police and crime commissioner I
think we are as politicians in a way
because you don't want to be seen to be
interfering politically in the running
of of police force that operational
Independence is important but we do have
a responsibility as politicians where
there is a police and crime commissioner
in sadiq's case or indeed you know the
Home Secretary has a responsibility to
make sure that the person at the top and
the culture of the force over which they
are responsible uh that they're held to
high standards and I think Sadiq acted
robustly he took criticism at the time
for doing that but I think he has been
Vindicated in his judgment even though
there are people saying that he went too
far too fast and was unfair to the
previous commissioner let's talk about
the the man's processing Migrant Center
and Lucy broke Powell said in group
where you were yesterday suggested that
there needs to be a better deal done
with the French Mark Harper setting
where you are this morning said
something similar is this perhaps a
point at which labor and conservative
can put political enmity aside and work
together on this because there can't be
many people in this country who do not
feel that lives being risked crossing
the channel in this manner is a good
thing well I mean you'd hope we'd be
able to work together and we've actually
got a plan the conservatives are welcome
to help themselves too it is about
working with International allies of
course it's also about resources we
think that the 120 million pounds the
government's spending on the botched
Rwanda scheme which is unworkable and
very expensive could be better used in
the National Crime agency tackling the
criminal gangs which exploit these
people whilst making vast sums of money
that's the heart of the issue and then
on a practical level there's much more
to be done on speeding up Asylum claims
the people who came on the boats last
year some of them have been waiting a
year still don't have a decision they're
left in limbo which means they can't
contribute to our society but no doubt
there are people in there who shouldn't
be here who should be returned home so I
think it's both the policy and the
practice that needs to change we've got
a plan the conservatives are welcome to
use it in a previous existence you of
course were involved with the national
Union of students you will and
fantastically they're thinking about it
I think I may well have interviewed you
when you yeah you are that old
thanks very much I think we're going to
the question and getting even more
robustly really dumb myself in here what
what on Earth is going on with the nus
this is not the first time that we have
seen a president caught out making some
pretty horrific at making some pretty
horrific statements not the first time
that racism has been found within the
union isn't it possibly time for the
government to step in and actually order
the nus to put its house in order well I
think and to be fair to the government
it's not often I say that but it's
better to the government I think they
actually withdrew from engagement with
nus which I think was a right thing to
do uh I I it's pretty depressing for me
as a former presidency an organization
which I think has an important role to
play in representing students making
sure their voices are heard by
University leaders by political parties
by government uh it's it's a shame it's
got to this point I do want to commend
the nus leadership however for gripping
the situation and acting in a both a
fair way but also a robust way because
students need to have confidence uh that
they're being well represented well yeah
the exiting president however has
claimed that she is the victor item of
sexism and racism she's not is she I
think it's important to acknowledge that
this was a case an independent casey-led
inquiry is my understanding obviously
I've not followed the ins and outs and
all of this but it's an independent
kc-led inquiry and I think some of her
publicly known comments were already
pretty reprehensible and I don't think
she showed adequate remorse or
Contrition but how do we sort a problem
like the national Union of students
well I think there'll be lots of viewers
who who frankly don't care much about
student politics and say this is all
trivial why are we even talking about it
um I I think that student politics at
its best can play a really good
constructive role and actually you don't
have a solution uh well I think I think
it's for them to to deal with I would
say to student union leaders look this
is your union you've got a
responsibility to step up and take
control because if I'd gone Rogue when I
was president of nus I would have been
held to account by student union so I
think there's a collective
responsibility on their part to step up
and get a grip of their Union because
ultimately I mean I can tell you that in
terms of Westminster and Parliament nus
has become an irrelevance and yet
students are having a really hard time
whether it's financial hardship
um the impact of the cost of living
crisis on students and the student
experience that we've that's been
severely disrupted during and since the
pandemic I think students deserve a
strong National voice and I think nus
can be that National voice and it's a
responsibility of student unions to step
up and support the new nus leadership to
do that right on you're preferencing to
be spent some time with Mr Harper
speaking about his tell us about the
cancer patients on the NHS waiting list
that you've identified as as going
beneath the radar the figures are
concerning that they are independent
experts estimate they're around 25 000
people on NHS waiting lists who have
cancer but haven't found it yet hasn't
been diagnosed yet and I know this from
personal experience when I was diagnosed
with my kidney cancer last year it was
actually for a scan for kidney stones
and so I know that within those big
backlogs more than seven million people
now waiting there will be cases of
undiagnosed cancer and that's why
Labor's plan for the NHS yes is about
gripping some of the short-term issues
and there are things the government
could do right now but actually it's
also a medium to long-term plan and the
biggest expansion of NHS staff in
history funded by abolishing the non-dom
tax status which would deliver more
doctors more nurses faster better
Diagnostics and treatment just to find a
word from you um on Matt Hancock and his
appearance on I'm a celebrity get me out
of here I've quoted that already this
morning but I'm going to go and do it
again as Deputy constituency chairman
says he's looking forward to see Mr
Hancock eat a kangaroo's penis I mean
what is your review and all of this we
can laugh and we can joke yeah but the
man has left the country at the time
that the covert inquiry is just about to
start yeah I have to say um of all of
the criticism that Matt Hancock has
received I thought the most stamming was
from covert bereaved families who I
think expect politicians
um to take that inquiry seriously and
clearly Matt Hancock has a lot to say
and contribute as health secretary
throughout much of the pandemic so I
think he's letting them down I think
he's letting politicians and our
politics down more generally because my
concern is that you know he says he
wants to go on there so people have
better access to politicians I don't
want people across the country thinking
that Matt Hancock is in any way
representative of politics just get
couldn't we just get the chief whip
support labor conservative lib Dems all
of you just to say right you know one
thing that you can't do whilst you're an
MP is going to here on you know you know
reality television I mean surely that's
a bare minimum that people can expect of
their elections statement of the blade
and obvious as well I mean I don't have
a problem with politicians going on to
programs which are not traditional
political programs in order to get a
message across to reach audiences we
might otherwise not reach because loads
of people are just turning off now
whenever they see politics
um I think this is extraordinary and
unacceptable in terms of the time
commitment that's involved and the fact
that being a member of parliament is a
privilege it's also a responsibility if
he wants to be a celebrity go and be a
celebrity we're not celebrities we are
politicians we have a responsibility and
a serious job to do and no one is
convincing me that he's doing it I can
also say that the I'm a celebrity
producers will be delighted at the
number of telephone calls going in
during every Bush Tucker trial because
we are going to make sure
um and I can say it's on a cross-party
basis
Matt Hancock gets his uh fill of every
people fully available to him in that
jungle West Street and good to have you
on the program thanks for with us